[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVE SMITH: Hello, everyone.
My name is Dave Smith.
I'm a Developer Advocate
at Google on IoT Platforms.
And I'd like to spend some
time talking to you today
about some of the
developer platforms
that we've been working
on, specifically
in the areas of IoT, and a
little bit about the Google
Assistant.
So let's dive right into this.
So computing has
evolved over the years.
We've gone from mainframes, to
desktops, laptops, to phones.
Every decade or so, we see
sort of this major change
in computing.
And now, we're seeing
computers literally embedded
into everything.
And while phones were
a very large jump
over PCs in terms of the number
of devices in the market,
we're expecting to see an
upcoming wave of IoT devices
with things
literally everywhere.
So we use the term "ubiquitous
computing" to describe this.
And it's this technology
that's accessible to the user
wherever they are and
whenever they want it.
And today, we're going to talk
about some of the platforms
that Google has been
working on to support
this particular effort.
In the past, we've
trained users to install
individual separate apps
on every siloed platform.
But now, we have devices
that are spanning
all over people's lives.
And some of these
devices don't even
have screens like we
would traditionally
use for a user interface in
terms of a mobile application
or a desktop application.
So we need to think a
little bit differently
about what computing
really means
to these particular users.
And we need to
take their context
into account in what we're
building-- their location,
their physical activity, time
of day, these types of things.
So we need to start thinking
about these individual apps
as actually just individual
views or unique surfaces
into a single application or a
single continuous or ubiquitous
service that can service across
all of these different areas.
We need to create a single
seamless experience.
So what I'd like
to do is walk you
through some of the
developer platforms
that we have here at Google to
help enable your apps to span
all of these surfaces.
And I'd like to start
with Android Things.
So Android Things was
recently announced.
We announced this as a developer
preview back in December.
And it's Google's new platform
to support development
for IoT devices.
And it's based on Android.
One of the most important
features of Android Things
is the use of turnkey hardware
through a System-On-Module, or
SOM approach.
And you see some of them
pictured here on the slide.
The SOM contains a CPU,
memory, wireless interfaces,
all of the important
electronics that
are necessary with a
common set of software.
And these are modules
that you can buy in bulk.
They're very inexpensive.
And you can plug them
into your own custom
boards, which can be
manufactured at very low cost.
This is all part of our
effort to democratize
hardware development
for everyone,
making it fun to
prototype, but also making
real possibilities
for you to build
commercially viable products.
The SOM enables commercial
hardware and some very
important features.
Android Things software is
a variant of the Android OS
that is optimized
specifically for IoT.
And we've added
new APIs that are
designed to help you integrate
better with custom hardware.
Beyond the device platform,
it also includes secure
and manage software
updates direct from Google.
These updates are managed using
the Android Things console
and are verified on device
for enhanced security.
We see many exciting benefits
of the compute power that
is possible in a device running
something like Android Things--
computer vision, audio
processing, machine learning.
Computing power in
these IoT devices
is increasing every year.
But at the same time, they're
getting cheaper and much more
power-efficient.
TensorFlow is one
of the examples
that we are seeing as one of
these great new introductories
into IoT.
TensorFlow has been
ported to Android.
And all kinds of hardware,
such as Android Things,
also supports this.
We've built a sample that
takes essentially a capture
of various images,
such as dogs or cats,
or other types of
breeds of animals,
and then allows the
device to classify
what those images are using a
pretrained TensorFlow model.
So the training is
done off the device,
but the device application
is able to process the image
from the camera
and determine what
it is by locally running
it through the pretrained
TensorFlow model.
It doesn't need any cloud
communication to do this.
It does all of it locally on
the device using those machine
learning APIs.
This is actually a sample
that we've open sourced.
And you can take a look
for more information
if you want to play around
with this on your own.
We also have this sample running
as a demo in the sandbox,
in that little
plastic Android head.
So I encourage you to
take that and play around
with it as well.
I'm not responsible
for what it says when
you point it at your friends.
All right, so let's
take a little minute
to talk about the
Google Assistant.
The Google Assistant enables
you to get things done
with the power of conversation.
It provides a new
and exciting view
into your app or service
for users to explore.
The Assistant is available
on a wide variety of surfaces
today, from the Google Home,
wearables, phones, in the car.
And we're working
hard at adding it
to even more surfaces over time.
You can extend the
Google Assistant
as a developer to
support conversations
with your own apps using the
Actions on Google Platform.
We provide a simple
conversation API
to give you raw
strings from the user
that you can use to
then generate replies.
This is an example of what we
built as a conversation action
around Google I/O. This is a
very helpful API because you
don't have to do the work
of parsing voice input,
dealing with text to speech.
All of that can be handled for
you through the Actions API.
However, you are still
responsible for interpreting
what the user has said.
And for a lot of developers,
maybe you don't necessarily
want to do that yourself.
It's a fair amount of
control if you need it,
but sometimes
there's a better way.
So we have a great
tool that is called
api.ai that does a lot of
this additional work for you.
So if you haven't
seen this before,
I recommend that
you check it out.
api.ai uses machine learning to
handle extracting entities out
of sentences for you.
It's much easier and
more powerful than trying
to write these regular
expressions yourself.
And it allows you to implement
these conversational interfaces
with ease.
It's a graphical
tool that allows
you to specify these intents
and entities for the data
that you're really
interested in out
of these particular
conversations.
And you can see
an example up here
on the slide of kind of what
this looks like with a sample
that we built for a
recipe recommendation app.
And essentially,
what you provide
is you give the tool a list
of phrases or sentences
that you expect the user to say.
And you can see that
api.ai is automatically
highlighting individual
entities out of those elements
that are actually interesting
to your application.
So for this case, it's
a recipe recommendation.
So we're looking for
things like a protein,
a temperature, a type of dish.
And all of these things are
just recognized automatically
by api.ai.
Now, the other really
nice thing about this tool
is that you don't have to pick
every single element that you
think the user might say.
Because of the machine learning
element to this system,
you simply have to provide
a number of samples upfront,
and then the system can
interpolate and interpret
what a user might
say so that you only
have to give it
some initial data,
and then api.ai will be able
to always do the right thing,
picking out all of the entities.
And then your
back-end application
simply has to respond
to that structured data.
So you no longer have to try
and interpret out of a string
the information that you need.
We've also announced the
Google Assistant SDK,
which enables you to embed
the Google Assistant directly
into your own custom
hardware projects.
We provide out-of-the-box
support for Linux and Android
Things.
But the API is based on gRPC,
so you could pretty much
port it to anything.
You can either use
a button trigger
to trigger the Assistant, or
you can use a library that we
have for hot wording support.
You can trigger it just like
we do with consumer devices.
All you have to do is provide
a microphone and a speaker,
and then you can use
the Actions on Google
to implement additional
functionality, such as Device
Control.
The Google Assistant also
supports home automation
via the Smart Home system.
Device makers can easily
integrate existing devices
with our Home Graph.
The Home Graph knows the
state of all connected devices
so that when you ask it to dim
the lights just a little bit,
it knows how to do that
in an intelligent way.
The user makes queries
to the Google Assistant,
and then Smart Home makes
calls to your cloud service
to control those devices.
As a device maker,
you don't have
to worry about handling
all of that speech input,
just dealing with simple,
structured requests with very
specific values.
The user speaks what
they want, and Smart Home
coordinates across all of their
devices inside of the home,
even across different
device makers.
Firebase also has
an amazing suite
of applications and services
that are useful for IoT.
Real-time database,
for example, makes
it easy to synchronize the
state of various devices
across a mobile app
and between various IoT
devices in your application.
Authentication, as
another example,
enables you to associate
devices with the user's account.
And with Android Things,
all of these features
are even easier to
integrate for IoT
because you can use the
same existing Android
client libraries and SDKs
right on those devices.
We also announced
Cloud IoT Core back
at Google I/O. This is a fully
managed service on the Google
Cloud Platform that enables
you to securely connect
millions of IoT devices
directly to Google Cloud.
Whether you want to
connect million of devices
and scale them
automatically, you
have no need to worry about
provisioning infrastructure
or adding individual
redundancies.
It has native support for
standard protocols like MQTT,
and you can access
all of your data
globally dispersed
as one single system.
It's very good for
enterprise use cases
where you need to do mass
scale-types of provisioning.
This is sort of converse
with the Firebase use
case, which works very well for
individual user-type home use
cases.
You can use cloud services that
are part of the cloud platform,
such as BigQuery, to analyze
your massive scale data
and visualize that for internal
use or for your users as well.
So that's sort of
a whirlwind tour
of all the different
services that we
have available for IoT
and the Google Assistant.
I want you to be sure to
play with all of the demos
that we have in the IoT sandbox
and the Assistant sandbox.
And our team will be on hand
to answer questions as well.
Immediately following
this session,
I'm headed over to
the IoT Office Hours
for anyone who has additional
questions about any
of these platforms, and you
can connect with me directly.
Later on today, we also
have hands-on training
for Android Things,
where you can actually
get your hands on some of these
devices, and play with them,
and build an application.
And we've got another one
for the Google Assistant
and Actions on Google tomorrow.
So be sure to check those out.
Oh, and one more thing.
We want to get you
started on the right path
by building cool
devices for IoT.
So everyone who has
attended this session today
is going to go home with one
of our NXP PICO Developer Kits
for Android Things.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
Make sure you grab
a card on your way
out from one of the
attendants, and you can pick up
your kit downstairs.
So thanks so much for your
time, everyone, today.
And I hope you enjoy the
rest of the conference.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]